let's talk about this madhouse and news
I have no idea what this website is but
that's okay oh it's actually being
reviewed by news guard look at this news
guards in the process of reviewing
madhouse interesting interesting I mean
I haven't read it let's read it
i google-searched you know alex jones
Joe Rogan nothing comes up this is what
I was able to find through it was on our
slash conspiracy on reddit this is the
article that posted and I watched some
of the video from Rogan he said some
interesting things and if this is true
there might be a really big Joe Rogan
may be about to use his weight
maybe it's inadvertent but it might
really break censorship Joe Rogan you're
the hero we all need yeah
well let's see yeah here's the story
right so again I don't know Maddow
snoozes but they say Joe Rogan says he
is going to war against Google and big
tech full stop no Joe Rogan didn't say
that Alex Jones said that Joe called him
and said this right no that is not
confirmed if you trust Alex Jones I
guess personally and I mean this with
all due respect I don't you know I'm not
trying to drag the guy I'm just saying I
want to hear it straight from Joe before
I just believed what else Jones is
saying Alex Jones exclusively revealed
Thursday that Joe Rogan signed an
exclusivity contract for his podcast
with Spotify as a way of striking back
against YouTube censorship Jones who has
been friends with Rogan for 22 years
spoke at length with the podcast king
with Rogen telling him that he should
announce to the world that the move is a
direct strike against Google that the
quote gloves are off and he is going to
war against big tech tyranny Jones told
his audience that Rogan had encouraged
him to go on air and put it all out
there the deal suggested to be worth 100
million . yeah sure Ali he's a
Huffington Post contributor very well
known high-profile journalist said 200
million that's an update I don't know if
that's true the deal would be worth 100
million was announced early this week
analysts are saying that it will change
the face of media forever
I agree Jones who has appeared on the
Joe Rogan experience numerous times also
announced that Rogan had specifically
requested in his contract with Spotify
that the Infowars host will be allowed
to appear uncensored on the podcast on
Spotify Jones said Rogan wants him as
the first guest on the show when it
arrives on Spotify on the 1st of
September follow
by Elon Musk who is also currently
speaking out against big tech censorship
and canceled culture the last time Jones
appearance podcast it was the most
listened to podcast of 2019 with over 17
million views on YouTube whoa Google was
subsequently caught shadow banning the
episode in an attempt to stop its
popularity what is this is it I don't
know about that let's see what they have
to say on this one oh this is a link to
info worse they say info war says Google
got caught shadow banning Joe Rogan's
number one podcast well we'll come back
to that
they say Jones said Rogan told him he's
sick of being treated poorly by Google
and the straw that broke the camel's
back was that Rogan wanted to interview
doctors and experts who have different
opinions on the corona virus to the
officially sanctioned narrative and was
told by YouTube that they would not
allow such content on their platform I
don't know if Joe actually said that but
I can tell you there was a former
adviser to the World Health Organization
this is going viral on Twitter I don't
know if I actually have the the tweets
pulled up but apparently World Health
Organization advisor gave an interview
YouTube pulled it Wow
yep creepy stuff they say Rogan also
told Jones the lockdown has provided him
with more clarity in the situation Rogan
has noted on his podcast that YouTube is
consistently D monetizing his content
and removing videos he told Jones that
he sees it not only as unamerican but
also anti human and excited Jones to
describe describe what I think maybe to
fry well it could be decried decreed
decree hello he said the move by Rogen
at was peak internet I don't know what
they're trying to say whether it was
positive or negative cuz discretion less
descried is a word I'm not familiar with
Rogen's podcast was downloaded 190
million times
109 times per month last year his
YouTube channel is 8.2 8.42 million subs
and the move away is sure to be a huge
strike against big tech fought to
control note2 readers whatever
so this links to the info war story I
don't know what their evidence that this
was being shadow Banda's let's see what
they say the video wasn't appearing outs
Jones returns and then you can see it
said here Alex Jones believed the videos
disappearance could be tied to real time
manipulation of the platform's
algorithms especially as his interview
with Rogan has recently begun appearing
as the top search result for the search
term Alex Jones on
YouTube I actually believe that's
possible because they did it to me just
the other day yeah so I did a video on
the lockdown and it did not appear so
for those are known at the context
lockdown and you know is happening
across the country in Virginia people
flooded to the beaches I did a video and
I said the people have spoken there
they're ignoring these these orders and
the video did not appear on my channel
so I raged it raised a huge stink on
Twitter and then this for you know and
then people are sharing the video and
the video started to pick up views
through direct shares now the video
actually preys on the channel so I think
I don't know what their strategy is I
don't play that if any of my videos get
Shadowman or censored I go full on every
other platform share it share it share
it and I ask everybody to share it and
it's only with your guys's help who do
share it that we actually break that
attempt at censoring the video so
YouTube I think there let me tell you a
quick story and we're gonna talk about
this is if this is true and if what
we're already hearing about Rogan if he
does Brianna Alex Jones gonna break the
internet and I mean in seriously but let
me first tell you a quick story or save
you Internet no I mean break it isn't
like the current structure of power it's
gonna be shattered I'm gonna be great
basically the same yeah it's gonna be
really really good really good mm-hmm
let me tell you a quick story a lot of
these companies know they can't take
instant direct action
they can't just ban me they can't just
ban Alex Jones they can't just ban Joe
Rogan Alex Jones was like over a long
period of time and it wasn't until like
one site pulled him that the other has
used that as a cover to try and get rid
of it immediately okay and it did start
a huge backlash so these companies know
that to purge channels you got to do it
slowly one at a time so you don't create
a big wave that hits the press and go
that's why we've been seeing people
banned on YouTube
they'll get banned and it'll be like one
channel and then everybody what's all
about but this is one channel so you
know one guy and then the next week it's
another Channel yeah and then another
channel how long ago was Alex bent a
couple years ago maybe a couple do you
know what it was bad oh there we go okay
so in order to actually make these
changes they do it slowly and they and
they learn this early on it's really
funny actually took Facebook a long time
the famous story is that eBay the
website used to be yellow okay
one day they changed it to white and
everyone complained I remember this so
they change slowly change together every
day they written one increment towards
white and then a year later nobody knew
changed yeah so we saw that with
Facebook too honey when they do these
instant rollovers everyone complains
same thing just happen with YouTube when
they switch to the new studio
everybody's complaining I was
complaining it was bad it was bad they
fixed a lot of the problem so I'm happy
with it but here's what I think you know
with YouTube they are absolutely purging
a lot of people yeah but Joe Rogan's too
big he's the biggest podcast in the
world so we had Alex Jones what are they
gonna do about it and everybody screamed
you can't do this he's violating the
rules and then I think it was was it
Logan Paul who had them on no no no I
don't remember
III don't know the Paul brothers are
like I can't tell I don't know they're
so but one of them had them on their
podcast what Alex Jones is saying if
Alex Jones really is guaranteed to be
the first guest for Joe Rogan on
September 1st Joe Rogan will force
YouTube to not censor the podcast and
and effectively not censor anything at
all after that it will be it will it
will be like but how does that work
though he's gonna be on Spotify not
YouTube is his podcast when he when he
launches on Spotify uh-huh
it will be still on YouTube and iTunes
so it'll be live on YouTube as well yep
okay and so you know that not live he
doesn't do them in live no no no it'd be
like published okay he's not doing a
live stream any of it right right right
here's my here's my general
understanding I haven't gotten any
confirmation or anything I'd like to but
if so Joe has said September first it's
gonna be on Spotify yeah and then later
in the year it'll become exclusive on
Spotify right right
that means there's there's this period
of a few months where if it's true
what uh what Jones is saying that Joe
wants to interview doctors okay but
YouTube says they'll ban him what's
gonna happen then on September 3rd after
Elon Musk comes on the show and Alla and
Joe Rogan has on this this World Health
Organization doctor who recently got
banned and YouTube says we're gonna ban
you and Joe goes do it
I'm on Spotify yeah YouTube don't care
and then everyone else is going to
at YouTube right they're gonna be like
do it YouTube Benham because he's on
Spotify well I'll go there no problem
yep and that's everybody's saying that
hey people are coming to me saying you
Tim Tim Poole and your show meaning this
show here and Joe Rogan are the only
reasons they're still on YouTube that's
it they're like if Tim gets banned you
know and and Joe's gets he's leaving
already
there's no reason for me to go to u2
anymore I think it's not the same as it
used to be I think this is why YouTube
likes me they-they-they there are people
who watch who used to watch a lot of
these I don't describe some of these
channels more right-wing channels that
eventually been you know banned Andy
monetized okay and there's an overlap
with I think it's more libertarian to be
honest okay there's a lot because
YouTube originally was very much
deliberate and committee not
conservative conservatives a relatively
new thing we've been watching the spike
in conservative channels but there
there's an overlap for the culture war
right with content like mine you know
anti sjw free speech all that kind of
stuff right so even though I'm a you
know of liberal sensibilities in terms
of policy that is completely irrelevant
the political conversation today no one
cares
lots of writers mean it anymore so
YouTube says we're gonna ban all these
people but then we're gonna lose all
these users who do we have they'll stick
around to watch then we'll they'll watch
Tim pool you know yeah they're like
great that way we don't lose the users
but we can get rid of people you know
these other people oh they're gonna lose
lose a lot of users I think without with
Joe Rogan moving yeah so yeah definitely
but I do think Joe will lose a lot of
viewers too
I do but here's here's just the the the
sledgehammer to the damn manhood
September 1st Joe Rogan has on Alex
Jones I don't know if that's actually
actually true I'm just I'm saying mr.
Dallas Jones is claiming yeah YouTube is
going to be put in a very very tough
position okay we are going to lose the
pod like the the king of podcast mm-hmm
unless we allow this content to it's in
the platform we're already hey hey
YouTube might say you know what we're
losing him anyway Banham yeah don't care
and they might hold their ground and
because joe said he's leaving
i think that's most likely i don't think
so no no way the bad press would be it
would be nuts
press would be insane that's true it is
the biggest podcast and then think about
the statement that would come out of
Spotify they would love it not if I
oh man Spotify would be like their new
commercial yup Joe Rogan absolutely made
the correct move and you know joining
the Spotify family yeah we will
absolutely protect his right to speech
and stuff and I'm sure Spotify has some
kind of like protections for really
really French characters mm-hmm but here
here's what it's all about man on Hulu
cuz we talked about this the other day
when we're talking about Joe doing the
Spotify deal
I can watch solar opposites from Justin
roiland where they cuss and swear all
night and is very adult and who's got no
problem with it it's YouTube that is
doing the weird censorship of like World
Health Organization advisers yeah and
real doctors so yeah maybe it is a right
move to get off this platform because
Joe's spoken about the censorship on his
show being bad I'm pretty sure I mean
actually I'm pretty sure we talked about
it yeah so Alex Jones is the first
person if that's true I mean it's gonna
be huge
that's a bold statement you know Elon
Musk being second I'm like I don't know
that's not an issue it's that if in this
time period where he's doing the show he
starts bringing on guests and YouTube
then is forced to ban him
it's Spotify is gonna be so happy yeah
especially with all the other people
that they've been slowing up slowly boy
yeah I'm talking about YouTube though
they're they're banning people they're
getting stricter people are getting fed
up with YouTube they're like what's
going on here so if this works for Rogen
it's like Spotify is gonna be like come
on this imma join our family come on and
they're just gonna explode I really
really doubt this but I feel like deep
down there may be someone involved in
this that understands the this gap
period where Joe will simultaneously be
gearing up to go exclusive on Spotify
but still be on iTunes and YouTube okay
will be an excellent marketing
opportunity for Spotify yeah think about
this way when you look at the comments
I'm like the Joe Rogan subreddit and
what people and on the YouTube videos
about his move there's a lot of people
saying I won't move I'm not gonna go to
Spotify there are people saying
r.i.p comments-section people saying you
know joe sold out stuff like that so
think about what's POTUS hold out
ridiculous yeah what does that even mean
like like he has any any allegiance to
YouTube right it's a fish he puts it out
there like what and plant isn't Spotify
there's a free version too I mean it'll
be free with ads right right so but so
so I'll look look at this way Spotify
knows they're not gonna be able to
convert most of his YouTube followers
right okay they're hoping that his core
fanbase bring bringing the show will
bring these people there and eventually
I'm sure out of the 8 million people use
4 million maybe 5 minutes a lot of going
over yes I already have Spotify I'm sure
that Joe's probably got a million
million unique individuals who are
guaranteed to watch the show every day
or listen to the show every day
yeah problem and then it's it's the
numbers above that you know so that
that's split between his podcast which
probably gets you know I don't know how
many how much is podcast gets but you
know out of the tour you know 3 million
per episode he gets 100 our core fans
who are always coming back that's maybe
a highest Amit I'm thinking would think
from from Spotify perspective they need
a catalyst to where the YouTube people
jump to Spotify so how do you do it
mm-hm you antagonize YouTube yep so in
this month of September that's this plan
Joe can be like I can have on anybody I
once I sign this deal with Spotify so it
brings on doctors and then YouTube if
YouTube does say episode 3 September 3rd
or whatever the date is I don't know if
the third was even a day that is let's
say Joe brings on this guy from the
World Health Organization who got banned
or those two doctors in SoCal who got
banned let's say you brings them on
that's what I want to see YouTube then
says we're banning this podcast and then
Spotify is a statement the podcast is
readily available for anybody would like
to hear it on our platform free of
charge it's unfortunate that YouTube
would engage in censorship and then that
says to all people on YouTube who are in
the middle of watching and way off you
know how many Spotify baby well that's
why I not cut it off it does make sense
that it's basically going to war against
the big big companies I think although
Spotify it I mean it is pretty big
company you know but I guess it's not
YouTube not YouTube big I mean I just
got a phone with Joe you just got off
the phone Joe Rogan Joe Rogan so I saw
this story you heard it here so he was
talking
Joe Rogan and I got some crazy stuff Oh
are we allowed to talk about it yes yes
it's a long conversation all right a lot
of you know just like BS we were like
complaining about censorship stuff yeah
yeah so and that's what it's all about
I'm sure right but well no no I mean so
so joe said he got a really awesome deal
yeah so he took it obviously yeah that's
just saying he is upset with censorship
yeah
Alex made a bunch us like he embellished
to an extreme degree output surprised
and Alex actually took it all down oh
really
yeah okay she took stuff down okay but I
can say some some stuff so Joe's not
going to war that was that was not true
the gloves aren't off that was that was
out Jones Alex was just saying all the
stuff you know and Joe was like he's
like man it's just a great deal and you
know I'm gonna take it and he did tell
me something really interesting and I
was like I'd to clarify this on the
record like is this legit he's like
definitely oh nice you guys ready for
this I am so ready I'm excited
when Alex Jones appeared on the Joe
Rogan podcast last time mm-hmm that got
17 million views
Joe contacted YouTube to warn them
mm-hmm they said okay and then monetized
it that's it
it wasn't monetized or Alex Jones had
been banned from the platform right he
had been purged
oh this was after he was purged yeah
okay I'm pretty sure and so in the midst
of all of these D monetization 's
happening all over the place yeah he was
like we you know we hit him up so hey so
you know alex is on the podcast right
and then they had they had forewarning
monetized it that raised a lot of
questions
mm-hmm why was out Jones removed but
when they got a heads up he's gonna be
on the Joe show yeah
to like huge press did they say run ads
on it huh they wanted to make that money
they didn't and they didn't care was
Alex Jones they didn't care and I was I
imagine he we're talking about it and I
said you know is the stuff about doctors
true did you say did YouTube ever tell
you no no no no no it's not the case no
okay
you know Joe basically said I have on
who I want to have on it's nothing like
that but he he does think he told me we
got to have some kind of
protections the way we do free speech
for the internet it doesn't make sense
that you're on you know this like you
yep you're on YouTube or whatever and
they can just remove you and you or
iTunes or whatever yep just as okay
we talk about a lot of stuff I want to
make sure I don't get into like you know
cuz we didn't talk about literally just
nothing but the the stuff right
he basically mentioned the gist of the
conversation when you go to Spotify when
you do a deal like this you've got
someone who asks you like how can we
help you succeed mmm-hmm when you're on
YouTube you're asking YouTube please
don't hurt me those are my words right
now but that's how it is yeah yeah so
yeah there it is it makes sense yeah I
mean it's true Alex took you down but I
I don't know exactly what Joe's conduct
anything like that is you know who's
gonna have on but I guess you know Joe's
like I'm gonna have on interesting
people and I'm not gonna have to you
know I mean is he gonna have Alex on I
believe so okay but I don't think it's
like the way outs framed it I'm gonna be
his first guest and you know yeah yeah
but uh I mean that's about it the
interesting thing I think is that the
monetization of Alex Jones I think is a
huge connotations like it's that's
that's serious that YouTube was
simultaneous of telling people like
we're doing these things for these
reasons then behind the scenes being
like yeah yeah come on let's get some
mad money money it's not email you under
you want to know what I think
at worst Alex Jones was making mad cash
on YouTube yeah YouTube wanted that
money no the only reason they got rid of
them was because the media was going
after them that means the advertisers
would pull out and they would lose more
money so here they found their sweet you
know double-dip yeah
oh it's not us you get mad at Joe Rogan
he had him on yeah yeah they got to run
the ads on it they got to deflect blame
hey we banned him you know we can't
control you know the biggest podcast on
Walton iTunes and so I think competition
is gonna be our saving grace yeah I mean
you know learning the stuff that Joe
never said this stuff does change a lot
of my initial reaction we had earlier in
the show yeah that you know it's gonna
but but I think it still stands all
right
Joe's concerned about censorship he
thinks it's insane that doctors are
being banned stuff like that but
not imagination or whatever no he's just
doing his thing but it is true in my
opinion because I don't think he thinks
too much about this stuff okay
that's if he starts having on you know
more controversial guests some of this
news and YouTube will be putting under
pressure you know you can't if you ban
this then you're giving away your
audience and that creates exactly but
there's another thing to consider too
that's with with with Joe doing a deals
big as he did it opens the door for
other creators who creates it expands
the industry yeah Spotify stock is
skyrocketing that's not surprising and
so how much money like you know are they
gonna make just in market value from
their stock I'm sure that they can you
know Joe Rogan saying I'm going to
Spotify boom their stocks guy right yeah
boom so now they're like okay because of
that now we got all this market you know
the market capital whatever yeah what's
that gonna lead to I hope so I just
found this out actually my my show is
one of the like it's it's on the front
page I guess if you if you go to Spotify
and scroll down it's like number 30
something on Spotify yeah even though it
gets like nothing yes oh cool like what
your shows on Spotify already oh it's
been a Spotify for a long time oh oh
right on right on yeah and then we're
your your main pocket IRL zone Spotify
right yeah I think so
yeah I mean I hope so yeah I'm excited
for this you know why if Spotify is
trying to get in the market that means
they're gonna do what they have to do to
make sure creators are happy yeah
YouTube owns the market so they're doing
what they can to make sure they stay on
the top well there's there's a few super
chats that people have pointed out to us
Spotify also banned Alex Jones back in
2013 so how do we know that Spotify
isn't gonna now they're getting all this
money and then like how do we know that
they're not just gonna suddenly be like
you know what maybe we should start
censoring and doing the same thing
YouTube's doing yep it's possible and
but it's competition right I think
what's not only YouTube anymore we
actually have a viable option outside of
YouTube and Alex so you better be
sweating YouTube and look no they are I
didn't know there there's Alex took the
video down I remember actually when I
saw that article I said I couldn't find
it right Alex had removed it oh that's
why yeah okay and so good at him for
doing the right you know taking it down
because he went off the rail
yeah but seems like he's substantially
more controversial and one of the
problems with Jones now is that he's
actually digging himself deeper doing
these things like where he was gonna eat
his neighbor's well now I mean we just
talked about it's like I think he was
just saying that because I mean sure
he's he's a vibrant person but at the
same time it's like you're not gonna eat
your neighbors man of course you know
he's saying it because he knows people
are gonna spread it around
exactly it did exactly that Alex Jones
was trending probably on Twitter I mean
I'm not sure but yeah he's putting
himself out there but today came a
saying with what he just said you know
Joe Rogan it's digging his hole deeper
hmm because now his conspiracy hole you
mean well no I mean like he gets banned
from all these platforms because he's
lying
no no just because he says controversial
bombastic things so then in order to get
more attention he gets even more
controversial how's that the word
bombastic yeah so there was a period
after he shot of getting banned where he
started toning the rhetoric down cuz he
used to say things like you know he
almost said he was he was gonna kill
somebody but he's like I woke I mmm and
then he stopped himself yeah because he
gets really into that you know and he
gets really excited and energetic uh-huh
and he's like oh I can't that's like
that's really bad I can't say that hmm
but they definitely got him banned by
taking a lot of things out of context
and like taking his innuendo and and and
metaphors take literally yeah but he was
more controversial I think he got banned
from a PR campaign but anyway long story
short YouTube I don't think they wanted
to ban him no no he was making a lot of
money that much was making them a lot of
money they were getting yeah they were
getting a huge chunk from all of the
views from his audience you know and the
only reason they reacted was because
when the advertiser said we're pulling
out they probably had a meeting it's
like a Fight Club where he's like if the
cost of a recall is right you know more
than the cost of paying people out we
don't pay it mm-hmm
they provide a meeting and they were
like okay how much do we make off Jones
per month and they were probably it was
probably in the millions some ridiculous
number and then they're like and how
much we're gonna lose from the
advertisers two million okay madam you
know it's like that sucks and then when
they find out he's gonna go on Rogan
they're like ooh we'll catch it what
caps up we will catch some of this gonna
be big yeah and then it's 17 million
views I don't know how much money that
is it's probably it's an hundreds of
thousand
yeah hundreds of thousands of dollars
that's a lot of use yeah so I'm excited
I think I think there's my deals gonna
be good things I I think so too
it's great for us yeah let's see what
happens thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you